economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge vamos a
comenzar hablando de los anuncios del
titular de la reserva federal de eeuu
que aceptó que la inflación va a ser un
problema a largo plazo así santiago y es
que tras meses de referencia a la
inflación como un problema transitorio
por primera vez el presidente de la
reserva federal incluso señaló que quizá
el momento adecuado de dejar de llamarle
así eeuu en ese país la inflación
interanual se ubicó en el 6,2 por ciento
del mes pasado el mayor nivel en tres
décadas según john powell presidente de
la fed la llegada de la nueva variante
omicron de kobe 19 y los hace evaluar a
acelerar la retirada del programa de
compra de bonos durante la última
reunión de la fed se dejó se en cambio
los tipos de interés en el rango de
entre 0% y 0 25% asimismo se anunció el
inicio de la reducción de las
inyecciones de liquidez en 15 mil
millones de dólares al mes el volumen de
compras mensuales de bonos que hasta
ahora es de 120 mil millones de dólares
se iría reduciendo progresivamente con
el objetivo de acabar completamente con
el programa a mediados del 2022 esto
será definido santiago entre el 14 y el
15 de diciembre cuando la fed se vuelva
a reunir escuchemos un poco que dijo el
presidente de la fed
el reciente aumento de los casos de kobe
19 y la aparición de la variante omicron
plantean riesgos a la baja para el
empleo y la actividad económica y
aumentan la incertidumbre para la
inflación una mayor preocupación por el
virus podría reducir la disposición de
la gente a trabajar en persona lo que
frenaría el progreso en el mercado
laboral se intensificaría las
interrupciones de la cadena de
suministro
'jorge esto tiene efecto inmediato en
las bolsas cómo les fue a los
principales parqués alrededor del mundo
y así este cuento vamos a iniciar con
wall street que terminó con pérdidas
acumuladas en sus tres principales
indicadores tras las recientes ventas de
pánico ligadas a la variante de micros
de coronavirus las acciones europeas
cayeron después de que el presidente de
la reserva federal de eeuu advirtiera
que la inflación estadounidense podría
no ser transitoria y en américa latina
la bolsa de sao paulo cerró negativo por
la duda sobre la recuperación económica
y la cuestionada agenda fiscal del
gobierno de brasil hablemos ahora de el
comercio mundial tiene una leve
recuperación al buen síntoma así es
santiago según la agencia de naciones
unidas para el comercio y el desarrollo
el valor del comercio global alcanzará
28 billones de dólares al cierre de 2021
de cumplirse la proyección representaría
incluso un crecimiento frente al valor
de los intercambios comerciales
internacionales de 2019 esta
recuperación del comercio mundial deberá
debería poner el valor anual de este
sector un 23% por encima del registrado
en 2020 con niveles récord en el tercer
trimestre por ejemplo entre julio y
septiembre pasado el comercio en el
mundo creció un 24% con respecto a un
año antes y un 13% en relación al tercer
trimestre del 2019 según la agencia pero
el crecimiento se ha ralentizado la
segunda mitad de este año producto del
aumento de los precios de las materias
primas y la presión inflacionaria el
informe tampoco tomó en cuenta la
aparición de la nueva variante del
coronavirus omicron así como su efecto
en la curva de la pandemia y su
potencial impacto en la economía en
plena campaña navideña hablemos ahora de
la economía de india una de las más
grandes importantes del continente
asiático así que bueno luego de la caída
histórica que sufrieron varios países
entre ellos india ocasionadas por el cob
y 19 las autoridades presentaron índices
de recuperas el gobierno anunció que la
economía creció un 84 por ciento en el
trimestre de julio septiembre con
respecto al mismo periodo del año
anterior hay que señalar que en el mismo
trimestre del año anterior la economía
se contrajo un 7,4 por ciento afectada
por el aumento de los casos del cobat y
por el estricto bloqueo que se dio en
ese país esta recuperación es impulsada
por sectores como la agricultura la
minería de la manufactura servicios
públicos transporte y comunicaciones
según un informe del ministerio de
estadística indio en la india- ubicó un
crecimiento del producto interno bruto
para el primer semestre del año fiscal
de abril a septiembre del 13.7 por
ciento parte del efecto rebote luego de
una contracción del 15,9 por ciento que
experimentó la nación asiática en el
mismo período del año anterior y la
cifra del día para el cierre esto es una
cifra curiosa 900 por ciento aumentó su
valor la cripto moneda de nombre o micro
en el mismo nombre de la variante del
cob y 19 o micro pasó de valer 65
dólares a 700 dólares entre el sábado y
el lunes pasado como hemos aprendido el
alfabeto griego con estos nombres que le
han dado a las variantes muchas gracias
jorge por esta actualización siga con
nosotros ya había en el debate buenas
noches
[Música]